[Music]
hope is with us in midland texas hi hope
how are you
hi how are you guys doing today better
than we deserve what's up
well first off i just want to say what a
pleasure it was to see both of you at
summit uh this year in dallas that was
very enjoyable thank you thank you for
coming it was a great event we had a lot
of fun
it was great
um
my question today actually uh just a
background my husband and i together
started our own business 13 years ago
and um
it's just
over the last four or five years it's
gone downhill he and i have a lot of
issues with communicating
almost to the extent of not
communicating at all but
it is affecting our business
a great deal because he and i are not on
the same page as far as
strategy how to how to go about the
operation of the business and get it
going
so i guess my question is what kind of
advice you might would have a
relationship as well as just keeping our
business afloat and moving it forward
when we're not on the same page at all
how's your marriage
uh suffering yeah because of it
it is it the chicken or the egg is
are they self-reinforcing one another
i guess as things were tough at home
they become tough in the office and they
become tougher at home and the thing
spins faster and faster
um have you guys
stepped away from everything and
gone over to dallas for a weekend just
to say hey what in the world's going on
or is this thing just started spinning
so fast and all of a sudden you look up
and it's a year or two later and you're
not talking anymore
um it's just kind of fun and then and
yeah like you said two or three years
later now
things are just so totally out of
control and we were talking to him when
he said there's a problem too
oh yes okay yes yeah this is one of
those moments that can
it can be a
really important it's going to be an
important moment either way but it can
be
something not to be feared it can be a
beautiful moment when there's redefining
rebuilding
start over rebuilding moments but it's
got to have to happen somebody's got to
turn the lights off i mean turn the
lights on turn the music off
take an inventory of the party you've
been having and saying hey where are we
what's going on
and
i love it when couples can look each
other in the eye and say hey we need to
do this and have this moment this we
need to take a post-mortem on what's
happened and decide where we're going to
go but somebody's got to just say stop
for a second
yeah you guys need you guys need a good
marriage counselor in your corner asap
to start with and just
the business will not heal until your
marriage does
right we we have done marriage
counseling literally a little about a
year and a half ago um
and apparently you didn't do it well
right
apparently not
why didn't it go well why didn't it go
well
um
he kind of just checks out um we've even
done business coaching and
you know i think two different
counselors a business coach uh literally
fired us a year and a half ago or two
years ago because he wouldn't
participate
um we were in coaching for 15 months and
he just
wouldn't do his part of it he would
wouldn't schedule for our our weekly uh
sessions things like that he just
wouldn't he just checks out and it's not
doesn't even give a reason just checks
out and doesn't do it
um and it was kind of the same way in
our marriage counseling i mean he
attended because we went together but
he would just kind of clam up and and
nothing really was being said from his
his point and he did tell me he didn't
like the the counselor
the marriage counselor that he didn't
like him he didn't trust him or
something and um
it just didn't go anywhere and literally
since that time we've just kind of quit
talking
literally
so your your your relationship
uh if you stop and step out of it for a
minute it's on life support
yes
um
and i would say you're you're in an
emergency status and it sounds like
you've got a guy that's that is
unable to say hey i'm done with this
thing is unable doesn't and i don't
blame doesn't have the tools or is it
coward or whatever you want to say but
he's unable to say i'm through with this
thing and he's going to slowly suffocate
it
and somebody's got to turn all the
lights on in that house and send the
kids away for a weekend and say we've
gotta we gotta take an inventory because
what he's communicating to you is he is
finished and he doesn't have the courage
to say he's done or he's scared of you
or he doesn't want to be in this
business anymore he doesn't know how to
say it out loud somehow
he is um
slowly pulling this thing underwater
counseling would call it the one down
position but he's drowning the house
slowly but surely
and um usually the your your role in
this is to try to keep yanking as hard
as you can the other direction and it
just creates this tension that ends up
sinking the boat anyway
so you've got to just stop stop the
music and say
are you done with this marriage i'm not
going to continue to participate in
crazy the way it exists no
i'm going to say
we're going to do something different
now do you want to work on this and heal
it
if you do that involves you finding a
counselor that you trust that we can sit
down with and that you're willing to
open up in front of and thus to get this
stuff fixed otherwise it's just going to
continue to deteriorate this is not
working you know continuing to do the
same thing over and over again expecting
a different result um
it's insanity and you know and if you're
seeking outside direction and you're not
taking the direction from outside that's
him there there has to be a reason yeah
and um
you know i can buy i i've sat down with
people that i didn't trust and i'm not
going to open up in front of them
absolutely i'm not doing that i can buy
that as a reason but the the answer is
not nothing then
the answer is go find a different
counselor right go find one you can he's
communicating to you if he won't find
another counselor that is a that's a
communication to you that i'm done
with this or he just doesn't have the
tools to to work this through whatever
it is but yeah you got to have somebody
in your corner at least guiding you
through these tough uh discussions that
you have got to have immediately the
business has not got a chance until the
marriage does all right john you are a
phd in counseling and you've done a lot
of trauma work
and you've done a lot of work with
couples over the years as well
if you were just gonna you may know some
research off the top of your head to
answer this but you may also have just
an anecdotal feel for it
when a spouse
for
uh virtually for for no
obvious reason that's on the surface
that's in front of us
turns away repeated counseling
and stonewalls in counseling
what percentage of the time
is there a third party involved in a
fair
i don't have any data but that's my
first
that's that's my that's my number one
question i always ask somebody are you
seeing somebody else
are you done right have you if they're
saying i don't want to work on this or
are they or they sabotage all the
counseling yeah by not showing up or by
showing up physically but not
emotionally
um not relationally and so on they're
not engaged in the repair right
that that will be one of the first
questions i asked if not the first is
are you seeing somebody else are you
through with this this interaction here
are you done with this person it's like
going to the doctor and the doctor says
let me do a checkup on you and you just
say no i'm good
and they say well here's some medicine
i'm good
like at some point you are deciding to
not be a part of the solution here and i
want to know why but yeah but
i'm trying to think of otherwise
the only other only other why that comes
to mind is somebody has such they grew
up in a family that's so maligned
counseling that's for losers or idiots
or psychopaths or crazies and you don't
need to go to counseling that's shrink
that's for yeah head shrinkers yeah it's
for losers maybe the
the sense of failure is so great
or man if i can't say the right thing to
make my wife okay i feel like i mean
that that makes me feel like a loser
right i get that and so it could be
something that shame is so heavy but i
want to rattle that cage and i'm going
to ask are you cheating on me are you
seeing somebody else right
um i just can't think of a reason other
than those two reasons why somebody
would it comes up i mean
again i'm not in that world but i end up
in that world too often because the
money you are in that world the money
piece ends up on the marriage plate the
marriage piece ends up on the money
plate and so i end up and i'm you know
this guy's completely disconnected this
guy was completely disconnected i can't
get him to engage in anything on the
money stuff and i'm like
they're not staying right for some
reason or another they're not staying
and sometimes when the person calls and
asks that question dave we all have
friends like this
my wife's crazy my wife's crazy my
wife's crazy you talk to your wife and
you go no brother you are right and so
it could be that this is round 10 of
some
thing that she wants to fix and he's
like i'm not doing another one of your
schemes because you won't participate so
you always get we always get one side on
the show that's true but so i'm not
saying that happened with her or him
necessarily
yeah yeah but but i but it just made me
wonder during the commercial break
from your perspective because you've got
a lot more professional insight than i
do on it mine's just an old guy hanging
around with a whole bunch of hurting
people for a lot of years and it just
gives me a sense of these things but
what do you think
i would say north of 50 yeah
that's my i just a wet finger in there
though i have nothing to base it on i'm
just
i just because i can't there
and it might be that they gave up on the
situation and then went and got the
affair rather than the affair caused
them to give up on the situation
that is but they're gone right they just
hadn't left yet that's right
some people don't have the tools i don't
know how to end the marriage i don't
know how to break up i don't want to be
the one that's the bad guy so i'm just
going to say up is hard
yeah there you go i'm just going to
drown this thing right slowly but surely
suffocated
um and then by the way on the way down
i'm going to make you feel crazy okay
yeah yeah so who knows but i i just
don't i'm not again we're not saying
that's the last caller no i'm not saying
that i just it just made me question and
made me wonder
i wanted and i wanted to ask you in
front of everybody else